[Music]
let's go to
kyle in manchester new hampshire what's
up kyle
hey john thanks for taking my call
brother say you're amazing and i'm can't
believe i'm talking to you a
i think you're correct
i'm just kidding
i'll make it very amazing but hey i am
happy to be talking with you brother hey
what's up man how can i help dude
so i
my question is i don't know if i'm an
alcoholic or if i have boundary issues
and i think it's that i have boundary
issues and the alcohol is more of a
habit but
you're the person that can probably help
me figure it out cool man so thanks for
the trust here what what's bringing you
what's making you ask this question
i mean
i i drink
quite a bit and how much you drink
uh
daily or five times a week um
you know quite a bit
how much when you when you drink
it's
i'd say i never have way too much to
drink but i'm also not the person that
has one to two drinks like i never black
out or anything but i
drink
almost to get dr if i'm gonna drink i
drink to get drunk so you get buzzed or
drunk
four to five times a week six to seven
times a week
yes yep yeah you got a problem
okay absolutely 100 okay okay yeah um
why do you drink so much man why do you
think you
why you have boundary challenges
and and i guess that's you know the old
saying you know you're the average of
the five people you hang out with most
and that's why i'm thinking of the
boundary side of it is because everyone
that i'm around all the time
is drinking everything involves drinking
whether it's fam and it's family members
family gatherings friends whatever like
that so
um
so tell me about these boundaries though
is it boundaries
meaning you can't say no or you don't
want to say no
or are you saying and doing things that
you wouldn't you wish you weren't saying
and doing
and you the common denominator there is
alcohol
yeah it's it's kind of both like i'll
say i'm gonna stop drinking
after the family barbecue but then the
family barbecue comes and i don't drink
for a week or two and then
before i know it the people that i
typically hang out with are calling me
and
um
one of the biggest people is
my brother-in-law and
uh i've been with my wife for 10 years
now but when
she was 21 and i was 22 and
my brother-in-law was 19. their mother
passed away from suicide
and
so since then my wife wants to be close
with her brother and
she's worked on all her feelings and
things like that but he hasn't and him
and i have become
extremely good friends
so it's kind of like am i doing it out
of the guilt that i feel for
i know that he's going to be at home
drinking alone if i don't hang out with
him so i ha i say yes to hanging out
with him even though i've committed
committed to myself that i'm not going
to be drinking as frequently okay and so
like that's why i that's the boundary
side of it okay
well
man the fact that you've thought through
it this this this deeply is really
really
incredible good for you man okay thank
you so backing out a little bit alcohol
use disorder i'm i'm using the
uh i gotta
mostly i hate hate hate love hate
relationship with the dsm but
um
hey james put a thing though we need to
do a whole thing on the dsm one day
um the
it's the psychiatric manual that helps
diagnose people alcohol use disorder um
out of the dsm-5 it's a problematic
pattern of drinking and it can be a
number of different things usually they
want you to have two or three of these
things but if you've tried to quit over
a period of time and you keep falling
back into it
um
drinking for longer than you want to
right having a strong desire or urge you
like man it's about three o'clock you're
like dude i just need to get down to
work so i can grab a beer um or two or
three right if you find yourself have
you just started skipping stuff
hey we need to get to work i'm good or
i'm pretty hungover or sounds like
you're a social drinker that drinks too
much but that you can
you can
scratch and claw your way through the
next morning is that about right
yeah and yeah and i would say i don't
skip things but like the family
barbecues for example everything's
everyone there or a lot of the people
there are going to be drinking so i go
and drink there and i don't skip it but
and i don't lay in bed all day or
anything like that i get stuff done that
i need to but i find myself drinking
when i do it okay
and what benefit do you get from it
honestly that's
i think that's my biggest
thing is like i was listening to the
call from uh august 30th with the woman
that was talking about how she how to
have fun without drinking but
i don't even do it for
the fun of drinking it's kind of like
and that's why i'm like it's
i'm doing work around the house so i'm
gonna have a few drinks you know
is there stuff that this
helps you numb from
uh i would say yes um i took that aces
uh test that you talked about yep um and
i took it three times because some of
the questions were like i don't know if
that is exactly what had happened but um
my score was three to five on that i got
three four and a five depending on which
one i took like okay which time and you
hopefully you read enough around there
that once you get into four and five
you're talking about a physiology that's
different your body works differently
because of some of the challenges you've
experienced right
yup
and when your body's running hot here's
the thing about alcohol dude it works
right it works
it does slow some of that stuff down or
it makes some of those those mundane
behaviors the ones that don't feel
reactive it makes you you can get
through them makes them a little lighter
for a while all right
so here's
you probably know this
but i don't
but i'm gonna say it anyway
i wonder if you know how good your life
would be
with
a full night of sleep without alcohol
involved
waking up
opening your eyes and smiling when you
wake up feeling light when you wake up
no headaches no backaches no knee
hurting nothing like that just waking up
and popping
up or
what it's like to
sleep with your wife of 10 years with no
alcohol
just y'all are
madly giggly in love with each other and
you're out somewhere and one thing leads
to another at least another that's
probably been a long time am i right
you're right right
so here's the thing
quitting drinking will cost you almost
everything
and i don't want to sugarcoat it for you
it'll cost you some family barbecues
people will say oh look at look at kyle
fancy pants cut right that will happen
right um it will cost you
relationships kyle sold out dude kyle
sucks he won't even drink he's so oh
he's so good
all that
right that will happen yeah and it will
be hard
um your brother-in-law who you love if
you really love him it'd be awesome
conversation to say hey we drink too
much
and i'm gonna stop and i want you to
come with me on this
and you can tell him how if he's your
great friend like you said he is you can
talk about your past and say i gotta
heal from some of this stuff you can
look him in the eye and say we gotta you
gotta deal with your mom
and we'll walk alongside you but we got
to deal with this
i love your sister uh love your family
but we can't go down this road and
here's the thing he's got to make his
hard decision on his own and he may not
choose sobriety he may not choose peace
he may not choose healing he may choose
a further trip down down the rabbit hole
right right right
what are you in for man
i mean you know like
i've i have
my wife and i have talked before and you
know we've stopped drinking for one two
months even over covet through the
holidays and everything and i felt great
and it's almost
i was thinking about right before i got
on with you and it's almost like my
identity is tied into drinking water
like that's right so the two things you
gotta change is your identity and your
environment
okay and and with the environment that's
i think where the boundaries is so hard
because
growing up growing up i never had real
friends or anything it was always people
that would steal from each other and you
know things like that but
now my
group is family so
those boundaries i feel like you know i
distance i don't talk to anyone that i
grew up with but
now the boundaries that i have to make
are with the family you know yeah and
dude as i say it's gonna cost you a lot
yeah and i is that like something i just
need to accept and
you know i know it's for the best but
yeah it's it's so here's a couple things
you can do number one know that you
can't do this by yourself
you can't just white knuckle your way
through this because it's going to cost
you so much it's going to cost you
relationships your brain is going to
scream for you to reconnect with people
who are in your gang
and so you're going to be fighting
alcohol on one side of the of the
equation right the actual
chemical dependency part
you're also going to be fighting the
dopamine pain balance dopamine is about
anticipation and the moment think of it
like i heard it the other day which i
just love from andrew huberman
it's uh he's a stanford professor he's
brilliant wonderful but it's a
teeter-totter and the moment that that
dopamine it's about anticipation it
feels good the moment you have that
first drink it over corrects with the
pain part
think of it as a teeter-totter and you
literally get a pain
your body feels pain and that's what
makes alcohol so awesome as you cover it
up
and then the moment it's over that it
thing starts to re-regulate itself so
takes 30 days of
nothing to get the chemical part through
right and at the same time you have to i
create a new identity and uh the way
i've done this in my life is backing way
the heck out getting one two three
people around me and to say i'm a guy
who takes care of their body
not a guy who snap it to a slim gym i do
this workout i'm a guy who takes care of
his body
and that has things that that informs
sleep that influence informs alcohol
intake that informs how i deal with
anger that informs how i exercise right
that means some days i take days off
because i'm exhausted because i'm a guy
who takes care of my body not a guy who
can do 500 does that make sense
yeah yeah and some guys which i love
their identity is i'm the fun guy at the
party
i'm the guy who always shows up no
matter what
and that's going to be a hard identity
shift for you and so whether it's your
wife i i would challenge you to get
somebody else whether that's a friend
whether that's an aaa meeting whether
that's a counselor those aren't for
everybody because of your aces stuff i
think seeing a counselor would be
awesome if you can afford it i think
that would be great
um
but walking through i gotta need to deal
with some of this childhood stuff at the
same time
i'm gonna abstain
and me and my wife if we've done it for
one month we've done it for two months
i'm gonna do it again
and i'm gonna have some hard
conversations with my current gang
my hope here's my dream and i'm dude
this is a fantasy this is like unicorns
and rainbows and ponies right
um is that you would be able to sit down
with your brother-in-law and say hey
dude we gotta stop
we gotta find different things let's
let's become runners let's be i don't
know you know the thing is
yeah um let's become guys who smoke
cigars together and go for walks
whatever the thing is right but we gotta
stop drinking and that means i gotta go
see somebody you gotta go see somebody
my dream is
my mythology for you is and your family
is that you could call the folks to get
together for the barbecue
and say hey everybody we drink too much
like i love you guys and i've got to
start taking care of my body you got
little ones
uh no no okay not yet are they in the
cards or or no
uh yeah they are um just
haven't had hasn't happened yet okay
awesome
so think about this as a
you're a guy
who thinks generationally
not you're not you're not a guy who
thinks hourly
right right and so you can start
changing your heart and mind and
behavior now
because you're going to be responsible
for hearts and minds tomorrow
it's wisdom right and right yeah and i i
completely agree because i grew up with
my dad being an alcoholic
but but he's
been going strong sober for i think
seven years now so um i saw the change
he made so i know that's what i want you
know have you thought about calling him
and saying dad i drink too much and it's
time for me to stop can you um
can we talk yeah yeah yeah i've i've
talked to him about it before and i have
gone to a couple of aaa meetings with
him
um
as support and just to check it out uh
but i've
because of those times i've been able to
stop for a month or two you know i'm
like
well i know i can do it on my own i just
i all i can hear is dave ramsey in my
head saying just decide yeah just decide
here's the thing
there is just a side
and part of deciding is knowing what you
can and can't do by yourself
mm-hmm right that's true so i'm just
gonna decide to start training for a
marathon tomorrow awesome
that means i gotta get a coach because i
don't know what i'm doing or that means
i got to get two guys to run with me
because i'm just gonna i know that i'm
going to need some people in my life
right
so just decide doesn't mean you're all
on your own and it's all you just aside
means i'm going to do some major things
i'm going to decide today i'm going to
be a better dad and a better husband
that means i got to deal with my trauma
that means i got to go talk to a
counselor or a pastor that i trust or a
close buddy that's been through this
before that can walk through this with
me i'm gonna have to get on the internet
resources and surround myself with fill
in the blank right so just decide isn't
a flex it's a submission
that makes sense
yeah definitely definitely so let me
tell you this
my greatest dream for you brother
is
that
you can sleep
you can just go to bed
and the greatest dream is that you look
at the work your dad has done that
leaned into the work you're gonna do
so that your kids will never know
they'll never know
you got both right right you grew up in
the home of an alcoholic which is his
own mess and your dad's done some hard
work
your kids won't even know what that was
that's like crazy right
and
i don't want to sugarcoat this this is
going to change everything for you
everything
and yeah
and
it'll be worth it
i yeah i know it won't be worth it yeah
yep
tell me out loud
i'm kyle
and i'm worth it
i'm kyle and i'm worth it and my wife is
too
and my wife is too and my grandkids that
aren't even born yet they are too
and my grandkids aren't even born yet
are they are too
that's hero brother
that's hero yeah got it do you believe
that
yeah i i do and um
i i
one of
if you have time for one more thing or a
couple more things
um or up against the clock so one more
real quick one
okay um so
i try to stay off by like
re retreat to
take care of myself and stuff but it
seems like something always comes up
like a family birthday or something do i
just stay home and let my wife go or
you know that's that's where having a
once you make this decision
and once you set up the parameters of
what that's going to look like aa is not
for everybody it may not be for you
maybe counseling is maybe a joining a
running group is right there's several
other options there what i want you to
do is i want you and your wife to back
out and create a world that you don't
have to hide from
i want you to create a world where you
can deal with
the mundane and the uncomfortable and
the childhood trauma and when your body
sets off you can stop and go what is
that about that happened to me this
weekend um i worked out way too hard i
ate way too less and uh way too little
and i was in the middle of a traffic jam
and i started thinking of stuff from
years ago and my heart took off on me
and then i started laughing
and said what are you doing
right it still happens but now i've got
some tools to deal with it and i didn't
have to pull over and go get gummy candy
let's go get gummy candy kids and ice
cream it or i didn't have to go stop
over and have a drink or what i was able
to just deal with it and then move on
okay
you can do that it's taking a lot of
work but you can do that
i want you and your wife to create a
world that you don't have to hide from
i want you to and your wife to create a
world together co-create this where
y'all laugh and have fun and it's an
adventure and it's exciting
and you can deal with the mundane
together and there's no alcohol in your
house period that's about the
environment
and
you got to get a gang you got to get a
couple of people whether it's somebody
from work whether it's somebody from
local church whether it's somebody in a
bowling well bowling
man there's nothing else to do when
you're bowling except drink but whatever
that is
yeah um
and then you gotta have a hard
conversation with your brother-in-law
then you gotta have a hard conversation
with your family
but do it in that order because if you
just run out there and say i'm not going
anymore
that's rejection to them it's rejection
to you you don't have anything to fall
back on you'll be drinking by the end of
the afternoon alone right okay right so
do it the right way and don't ghost
people
it will be hard but part of who you are
and your new identity which is i'm a guy
who loves his family i'm a guy who tells
the truth i'm a guy who takes care of
his body part of that i'm a guy who
loves his wife i'm a guy who loves kids
that aren't even born yet part of that
will be truth telling and when you tell
the truth and you have hard
conversations you will find yourself get
stronger and stronger and you're going
to need it because they're going to
reject you and they're going to get
pissed off at you or maybe just maybe
just just just maybe
they're gonna get a tear in their eye
and say
so grateful somebody finally said
something thank you so much maybe
probably not but maybe
and you're both cursed with a father
who's an alcoholic and blessed with
somebody with a father who's seven years
sober call him and say i can't do this
by myself anymore
and i'm ready to make some changes
tell your wife that today too
tell your wife that today too if you're
struggling with alcohol
which a lot a lot a lot a lot of people
are
there's freedom on the other side of it
it's a lot of work it's going to cost
you almost everything
and it is worth it you
are worth it